[Music]
in that was easy news excuse me
there the camera would pause be on your
angle old excuse attracting we're
[ __ ] romantic ran out we're just
talking about how we're about to have
sex long Oh God that's not romantic you
don't talk about it you're supposed to
do it right yet the schedule about okay
we're talking about how it's gonna go
down all right speaking of speaking of
gon sex and that was easy news oh but
I'm boom y'all miss my jello girls a
good one oh yeah easy like a Sunday
morning submitted by senior caballo oh
ho mr. horse nice to meet you huh it's
nothing wrong there's nothing wrong yes
yeah I mean there's a what I do you know
that one of my favorite things to say in
Spanish in high school was megusta
Montero el caballo rapido cuz I just
thought it was funny what if you like
you don't need Spanish I'd be like oh
yeah yeah that's worth rather watch got
some facts about the past
Oh Mount Oman that means mountain yes do
you want that of girls too
oh yeah you right correcto I don't want
to [ __ ] man allegedly use a change of
address form to move a UPS headquarters
to his apartment
yo some of these people are [ __ ]
smart yeah that's right I don't think
that's a good idea
you're a bunch of random [ __ ] alright
that they find these loopholes I mean I
easily did it
so packages were getting sent to his
house he was getting everyone's packages
no so this was the company's mail so
they found out that it was UPS mail and
so including checks oh this will
actually deposit it about
thousand dollars worth of checks that
word for employees oh damn
[ __ ] thief his name is - he went and
it went straight to his house yeah what
an idiot
you USPS just easily changed the address
of an Atlanta UPS corporate company and
so they ended up changing it to his
address in Chicago damn that's so much
[ __ ] paper trail this guy's an idiot
idea for a long time he changed it in
October they didn't catch him till oh
three months like January that's crazy
though that sounds like ups to me I know
right
yeah FedEx is the way to go the idea was
genius the execution was what boss too
big there's a UPS package that my friend
said to me should have been on my place
but it's not here yet so I hope you see
this UPS uvs UBS yes you get drivers
that drop off packages and say sign but
nobody signed for it you know what our
stupid UPS does look you get all our
amazon packages from the entire um
community and they just leave it because
we have big mailboxes forever the whole
everyone they just leave all of the
packages on top really yeah they don't
take it to the door even at our other
office they used to but then now they've
been doing that so people wouldn't
complain like a month yeah that's
annoying yeah I I you you do have to
complain and they will change it do
change they change so this [ __ ]
I literally caught this fool with a
package of mine and he just chucked it
over the fence huh no there was no
fragile [ __ ] but it doesn't matter like
he literally went went up to the fence
and I'm coming down and he goes I see
the guy just launched it over he's
practicing his football and I was like
it wasn't just my it was all the
neighbors [ __ ] she's launching it well
if there's a [ __ ] iPad and he threw a
[ __ ] so this person was getting
furniture right so there was a dining
table stuff and then it was like a
tabletop for there he threw it over to
and I just went I was like yeah what the
[ __ ] man then I was like bro you cannot
do that [ __ ] house I brought cuz it was
him and also the previous USPS guy that
was doing that [ __ ] maybe they all like
to do that it's like we're all in the
same team it's all [ __ ]
hey chicken want to do his Korean dudes
package right
these through all of our [ __ ] and he
just like I just don't report me man
please it's like well don't break our
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude you have the code like
you know the code right because she just
ordered even if you didn't [ __ ] or you
just open the gate so annoying and the
place didn't side so I ordered wine
glasses and then recorded anything yeah
and then you open up the box see he
ruined my wine glass sued Amazon yeah
you could have got a million dollars
dude it was like my thing is to I don't
want to get anybody fired cuz it's there
a way of living
yeah I mean but it was just I don't care
if they're doing that I would like dude
you should have work here if they're
throwing packages like they're [ __ ]
footballs I can't believe you threw a
piece of like a dining table over you
know what I mean and that's really heavy
too you're pretty strong bronze David
like it's like the size of it it could
have been a baby in there true she's
[ __ ] ridiculous
it's literally in the shape of like a
dining table is there no in the shape of
a baby like a cardboard box and it's
just like the shape of this table and
it's just he just chucked it over I was
like come on I feel like if a boxes
handle with care this is the way to
handle it yeah cuz I ordered light bulbs
once and it did say fragile and they
were all shattered man it's like that oh
I did used your box to step over the
fence it's for soccer practice soon and
then I ordered it's like some soap or
something like a gallon and then they
threw it over and like everything is Oh
that's annoying I don't like that [ __ ]
annoying that's annoying that's why I
like my Amazon dude man
mother [ __ ] always comes up places it
right in front of your [ __ ] door and
wide oh my mother [ __ ] huh I don't
know I used that word for everything
that's in Jerry no it's a term of love
cuz he's saying this guy can [ __ ] my
mother if you watch I'm gonna let him
thank you Tim it's not like if you're
watching Amazon a guy do not I do love
old Korean women I know I'm saying like
finally I know that Korean ask for a
long
good luck bro my mom's a [ __ ] they like
them feisty yeah yeah so this dude um so
finally they inspected because they
realized that they weren't getting their
mail you after [ __ ] how many months
yeah hey having got that check guess oh
then postal inspectors searched his
apartment and found about 3,000 pieces
of mail Wow address to the company that
was supposed to be Atlanta right
thousand yeah and so he told that the
[ __ ] ten boxes yeah he told investigator
it was funny because on the application
of the change of address he signed it
with his initial initials but then
crossed it out and put ups Wow
professional so that no but it still
went through yeah the crazy thing like
USPS can't even check no one cares up
there you know no one's like inspecting
[ __ ]
I don't you PS that for United Postal
Service the other one is United States
Postal Service USPS yeah yeah so um yeah
another investigating and they're trying
to see like because there apparently
there's a lot of what no nothing cuz
music yeah what does FedEx stand for
federal race and all services DHL I
heard DHL is good for international know
when the girl got them da chels
dear sir cable take servicing lips
dick-sucking
I know Oh dick sucking lips sucking lips
what the [ __ ] are we talking about right
now dude [ __ ] this guy all right that
dress-ups address yeah but that's why I
like Amazon gifts every day like
Christmas I love it too but then I also
feel bad like you people and their
regular huh all the cardboard for sure
all the people just in the regular car
like they just look like just like
they're into it they don't work for
anyone and they just so happen to get
your box at their house and they're just
bringing it back to you but that gives
them money no no it does but now they're
just putting miles on their own car
opposed to like it being you like in an
Amazon type car where it's like made for
handling packages that's funny have
their own store like you feel sorry like
that's that their own what but they make
you a story yeah it's just oh it's the
people is that how it works that's their
own store and that's the deliver no he's
a nice he created story Oh story yeah
it's like oh poor [ __ ] you know what
you said you had a reverse mind blown
moment you had story I was like oh [ __ ]
once the horse that's died
yeah definitely Amazon are you a person
that's a little bit lazy just a little
bit yeah I mean like simply just on the
way I could just go to a store and get
the toilet paper and it's cheaper you
know it is cheaper like you know like
regular toilet your stuff is cheaper
store you Amazon toilet paper yeah
really yeah Wow it's pretty [ __ ] lazy
of me
you buy everything really everything I
don't have asan anything I don't even go
grocery shopping anymore men I do
something called instacart you actually
go I'd go to the grocery store I go to
stater brothers down the street spider
brother
in farmland origins 4:29 thanks they
even have prime for the food stater
brothers prime know and they probably do
partner up with state of risk another
partner with 99 Ranch 299 much that's a
collab yeah way more expensive and they
have a limited but my time is way more
expensive but what if they don't have
what you want
I kind of like going on the grocery
store it's kind of fun yeah and you know
it's crazy it's like I always go it's
all be it's like 3:00 a.m. and I'll be
like [ __ ] I need groceries and then I go
to this 24-hour grocery store and it's
just like it's fun I'll hit a break
sometimes Rick's awake I'm like hey bro
you wanna go 24-hour grocery store with
me and then he's like yeah okay your
girlfriend yeah we go buy pizza rolls
you know what's funny get married right
and then she is gonna be in there too
you're still gonna call Rick well here
you know it's cute well here's the thing
well so me and she you know when she's
in town I I never buy groceries like I
post me all my food unless she is coming
and then or what she's here then we'll
go buy groceries and then one day she
was like she was like I like I like
grocery shopping with you because like
it makes it feel like a normal like
they're a family yeah because like you
know we're used to you know this
long-distance [ __ ] but it take more
buying groceries together it's like okay
now it's like tell me it's me yeah tell
me that it's me oh yeah it's all we have
to do it's up to me here
there forever more pop a picture you at
the grocery store pushing a cart with
chair getting [ __ ] cereal and [ __ ]
it's so romantic
yeah man and they grab the same box yeah
at the same time that we fall in love
wish Muriel could follow a recipe book
and then my life would be set
[Music]
[Music]